est ce que pourrait dire que pour faire
cette modélisation et cette micro
simulation démographique comme vous
l'appelez dans l'article en tant que tel
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'elle sait bars
et beaucoup sur le système d'immigration
canadien et comme vous dites fait une
sélection plus et 3 10 ans dès lors de
ses six militants mais donne dans le
modèle de micro simulation l'humain il
ya des milliers de paramètres
je n'ai pas compté mais lol jamie est un
cas m mais ce qu'on fait dans l'arctique
c'est des scénarios où l'on modifie ses
paramètres pour réaliser des scénarios
qui n'existe pas mais qu'il pourrait
exister
et puis on parce qu'on est canadienne
mais pas seulement pour ça surtout parce
que le canada une politique
d'immigration qui eux qui lui bien vu
partout dans le monde comme on voudrait
peu comme le canada mais c'est pas donné
à tout le monde et les frontières
canadiennes sont faciles le garder on
une frontière la plus longue au monde
avec l'espace ni mais les états unis et
certains pays de l'ex de côté mais c'est
pas le pays d'émigration massive comme
peut en fait c'est ce cri les pressions
migratoires se font souvent des cars de
revenus ou et de richesse entre deux
pays le mexique vers l'estonie celle qui
fut la même chose en europe aussi on
voit que des visites en 2015 lui la
crise mais des réfugiés en sang athènes
ça continue de beaucoup dans l'africain
ou de friction qui tentent de traverser
dans des conditions épouvantables de
méditerranée pour avoir c'est une
espérance d'une meilleure vie ou encore
des gens du moyen-orient avec les gays
lesbiens ligne la version de ce type
après la grèce
on n'a pas ça ici au canada d'une classe
on ne la contrôle de ce qu'ils ont aimé
l'attitude est figé conques sélectionne
aussi à certains 10 mais on a donc une
des caractéristiques différentes
populations migrantes par rapport à la
population de d'autres pays
si donc un des scénarios scénario
canadien effectivement où on se pose est
que les immigrants qui allait en europe
était pour avoir des caractéristiques
semblables à ceux des canadiens parti ou
de modification et aussi au niveau des
dix niveaux d'immigration au canada on a
aussi un des niveaux d'immigration le
cul les plus élevés au monde
en fait notre tou l'immigration est deux
fois plus élevé que celui du rhum